hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is uh Saturday
January 14th and you know I I want to
get this video out there because you
know Saturdays is a nice day to catch up
on your studies of the markets you know
and try to look at the order flow
footprint and figure out you know some
of the things that you should be keying
in on you know when you're watching a
footprint chart and again you know I'm
not doing these videos to give you uh
trades you know I'm doing it to get you
to think so you could make those
decisions yourself so when you're
looking at a footprint when you're
trading by yourself because I'm not
gonna be trading standing behind you
telling you what to look for I want to
teach you
what to look for so if you've been
liking these videos I've been trying to
be pretty active and get them up about
once a day be sure to subscribe to the
channel so when I do post a new video
you'll get a notification and if you
find you get anything out of it by all
means you know like the video all right
so what I want to talk about today
is
you know Trading
you know markets that aren't as popular
as say the the equity indices right the
mnq or the NQ or ym you know the mini
Dao es or mes you know because there's a
lot of other markets out there and
unfortunately though with these other
markets they don't have that volume that
you see is as a in the equity indices
and
um today I'm going to be talking about
I'll be talking about five years I'll be
talking about one of the grain markets
so first in the five years because you
know five years is one of these markets
that I've always told people in the past
since you know I started working with
retail Traders
um you know almost 10 years ago
as a market that you know
for people to get experience right now
you know now there's all these funded
programs you know and say what you want
about them you know I have my own
opinions you know having skin in the
game so to speak is the best way to
basically hone your skills so to speak
right I mean it's one thing to paper
trade and you know be in in a in a try
to get funded you know that way
um but when you have your own money on
the line it it should sharpen your yours
thinking skills all right and one of the
markets I used to recommend to people
was the five years the the ZF the five
year notes
and obviously the main reason was
because it was uh at a very low margin
it was only like 250 bucks a contract at
amp it used to be I don't know what it
is now but it trades in quarter ticks so
a tick is like seven dollars 81 cents
and it's not a market that you're going
to get these big price swings you know
20 ticks in in 30 seconds as you would
in say the es or mes so and it's liquid
so if you need to your exit the position
there's liquidity there at least at
either on the bid in the offer or the
next bid in the offer you know you've
seen sometimes in these Equity indices
you try to get out you're filled two or
three four ticks worse than you know
when you hit the sell button or the buy
button
but the problem with that is if you're
looking at a time-based chart
you get a lot of this right which is
hard to analyze in the order flow where
it's just basically trading One price
right the bid and the offer
more or less for extended periods of
time and
if you're trying to analyze a footprint
chart you know ideally you want to see
some movement in the market and if it's
you're getting you know some movement
but it's taking you
20 minutes to get a little bit of
movement on a minute looking at a minute
base chart isn't going to be very
effective and for interest rates I've
always
recommended a four range chart even a
five range or you know again even a
three range but you want to have some
movement because you want to be
understanding what's happening in the
Overflow as the markets move now there
are strategies for markets that aren't
moving
but those strategies are more for you
know markets that aren't moving that are
trading you know decent volume above and
below the bids in the offer not
literally just trading one price so
if you go to you know a three or four or
five range chart
um you're gonna start to see some
movement so I'll just put up a three
range chart but again a three range
chart is about as
low as I would go okay
excuse me so
what I'm looking for is basically the
same thing as I would be looking for on
an e-mini
mes crude oil Etc
you know I'd be looking for the ratios
and divergences all right like you have
here
right the two blue and gold arrows right
I know this is a Divergence it's a
neutral low with positive Delta and I've
got my bullish ratio here right see the
market go up and it's running into some
resistance up in here you know I read
the Delta the same way I see the
positive you know Market coming down
Delta is getting a little bit weaker
2700 300 49 177
1687 and the market starts and goes up a
little bit but it runs into Supply and
the market drops back down
um you know here's another Divergence
um here right I love prominent pointed
controls okay and in this case this is a
point of control on the extremes means a
red candle with the point of control up
near the top you got the bearish ratio
so I I know that theoretically there is
some stopping volume
in this bar in this bar as the Market's
moving down that's what I want to know
right and again whether I'm looking at
an e-mini chart
or a five-year chart I'm looking for the
same things
okay because they're going to manifest
themselves whether it's e-mini or
five-year 10-year crude oil
um you know and again you know I see
here another bearish Prominent Point of
control and again it's not like just
because you're looking at a different
Market you got to take everything you
know about order flow and throw it out
the window no you know you're looking
for the exact same things you know
here's a ratio
here in the Divergence here starts to go
up then it fails then you get the same
sort of setup coming in here again and
then finally you get the move
okay now this is a five year now five
years trade decent volume you can see
you know each bars are trading you know
several thousand contracts right and in
the bars these price levels are trading
you know several hundred contracts but
what about markets that don't trade a
lot of volume but sort of move the same
way
um you know a good example is soybean
meal all right now again you know
I'm not advocating people go out there
start you know trading meal or trading
five years but I do know that there are
other Traders out there that are
interested in some of these other
markets Beyond you know because they're
just burnt out with I mean yes because
it just moves around a lot and the nice
thing about the slower moving markets
that don't trade all that liquidity is
they tend to follow order flow better
and you know the reason for that is
because they're following supply and
demand because the people are trading
soybean meal people that are trading
five-year notes
have a reason to they're not necessarily
speculating although there's speculators
in those markets but the overwhelming
amount of trading is coming from you
know people that are involved in the
process you know like you know I'll say
the farmers but
um you know traders that are that are
buying or selling soybean meal based on
their business right that's what their
business revolves around you know are
people trading five years you know
they're trading the whole yield curve or
you know they're hedging something
things like that it's not just people
taking speculative positions so this is
the um soy meal okay now let's take a
look at a minute based chart
and then I hit that okay let's give it a
second here to come up
okay
Mouse is acting up here okay so let's
just go back now soybean meal there is
an overnight session but the main
session opens up at 8 30 in the morning
you know where are we here
scroll back okay so here right 7 45 then
reopens at 8 30 this is the main session
and
now you're seeing you know look at the
volumes here right so this is a one
minute chart and you know right after
the open that's where you're going to
get a lot of the volume 500 600 but then
everything else during the day it's
pretty tame there are some bars with
some big volume 453 but everything else
96 90 72 61. you know this is 199 you
know a couple bars with 200 but
in a market like this again same things
I'm going to be looking at how we're
trading relative to the low or the high
or if we're coming in at a swing High
where's the Prominent Point of controls
coming in here right which acting as
support I can see the volume coming in
here
um 48 on the bid 103.52 right so there's
big liquidity here
right and you see the market rally up
from that area you test it once twice
three times
to an area where you're getting some
stopping volume 126 on the offer this is
a bearish prime reporting control so I
got a bullish problem important controls
here followed by a bearish one
what do I think is going to happen well
I think it's probably going to drop
right and you can see it starts to drop
down okay coming back down
again I'm just I'm looking for you know
areas of where a market can turn based
on where the volume is being traded okay
see sort of comes back up here is a
bullish Pawn reported control
and then it's coming back down into the
low of the day okay makes a new low
some heavy volume here 209 okay did it
stop the move not really came down made
it lower Low by two ticks then started
rallying back up a little bit but
nothing really to get too excited about
you do have a Divergence here
um you got a zero print here which
technically is a ratio but doesn't go
anywhere over the next couple of bars
just sort of goes sideways and then
takes out that low takes out the low
again by a tick again nothing overly
bearish coming in here but not again
nothing overly bullish coming in here
off this low
okay then you're starting to see some
interesting things here in the order
flow it's just going sideways but then
again you're seeing this volume coming
in here like you saw earlier 53.85
right these are two bullish prominent
pointed controls that's what this
magenta line is just like over here
earlier this area right the 48 the 103
the 52 and you got a bit of a rally
people say well you know it's soy meal
yeah it's soy meal
you know if you take it from 42 and a
half up to 43 and a half it's a hundred
dollar move basically which is you know
I don't know for some people I guess you
know they'll scoff at that but that's a
decent move
um to be had
uh you know then again again you see the
testing these these two areas right in
here
479.80 and again it goes up from around
you know 480 50 up to 480 150. it's
another 100 move then it comes back down
right you got your bearish primary point
of control there and it comes back down
into these lows must starts making new
lows yeah Divergence no reason to buy it
here got a Divergence not really any
reason to be behind it down here either
because you don't have the bullish
ratios
well this is where it gets interesting
right since we're talking about volume
right this is by looking at these
markets that don't trade a lot of volume
you really get the key in on the volume
okay which is a bit different than the
e-minis because you're so used to heavy
volume but if you're trading in a market
that doesn't trade a lot of volume it
really stands out a heck of a lot more
and what do I mean is look at this bar
so we made a new low here
then this bar it's got a big negative
Delta it's a green candle
oh Mike I got big negative Delta
shouldn't the market be going down well
why is it happening this is what
using a footprint allows you to do is
allows you to look at the volume and
where it's transacting well it's
straight transaction
transacting on the bid 477 and a half
bid so what happens Mark is selling off
then someone it got down to 476.90
and then bidders buyers are coming into
the market right to say hey you know
what we just dropped from 482
down to 477
yeah I like that I'll be buyer here at
477 40 or 477 and a half yeah they're
coming in
102 26 starts ticking up a little bit
172. another big negative Delta right
minus 105.
all right I didn't get these two big
negative Deltas but the bars are green
the Market's going up wise because you
have support coming into the market
they're talking about Market generated
support this is a perfect example then
the market dips back down dips back down
to where 477 30 which is a little of
this bar
but down to that 7740 where you traded
102 earlier now you transact another 71
contracts there
so imagine you're at your low of the day
you're seeing
nice supportive buying coming in a
hundred
70.
172. what is that 100
200 when you had these two together the
26 and 71 300 you know close to
close to 400 contracts going through
here at you know between 77.80 and
77.40.
okay buy it right because what's your
risk well the risk is just down here at
690 the low because I know that buyers
are stepping in actually your risk would
just be you know somewhere down in here
around 77 you know we need to go below
the low
and you know you can be looking for that
move back up okay
so
if you're looking for a move back up
this is the thing
don't get married to the trade you want
it to happen sooner rather than later
because now you know buyers are
attracted to the market and they're
acting they're giving you some support
okay so if you're getting long you know
call it somewhere in here 77.60 just you
know rough
okay and it starts to move up 77.60 gets
up to
almost well I'll say 78 60 just trading
one but it is trading up in here around
78.30
and this is where it comes into watching
your trade managing your trade okay your
stop is down here at 77.10 so about a
five tick stop it's just sort of hanging
around okay again I like the moves that
happen sooner rather than later okay so
uh you know it's now it's trading 78 70.
it's just hanging around here it comes
down here 78 get some supportive buying
coming in where is the move
all right you're getting long in here
10 37 10 38 in the morning it's already
pushing 11 o'clock it's just sort of
hanging around here that's not a good
sign you're in a trade for a half hour
you're still in the money which is good
but it's not really paying you that's
where you have to start saying
okay
what's going on do I want to stay in the
trade or not
okay and if you stay in the trade comes
back down to your entry price pops back
up again this Market is telling you
book it take your profits get out now
you're starting to see some bearish
things come in here in the order flow
bearish Prime opponent control another
bearish problem important control does
come back up right it looks like oh you
know this is the problem that a lot of
Traders face they hold on to a trade too
long
because you know the reason for getting
into a trade it has a lifespan
okay it's not something that you should
be looking to carry on forever
and then this is what happens right you
get into a trade an hour ago and it's
just sort of hanging around in the money
in the money then it looks like it's
going to start taking off right oh I got
my
a big support of buying coming 111
trading on the bid okay and it's coming
in just after an area where you had some
resistance
okay because you remember here 25 40 and
this is coming at the same level so it
cleared it and it's gone bid over at 479
and you're thinking this is it you know
you're rubbing your hands together now
you've been in the trade for about an
hour
what happens it goes up a little bit 79
479.70 just sort of hangs around hangs
around and it just keeps hanging around
that area I mean at some point you got
to be thinking
I'm not getting paid on this trade
right I mean you are because you're in
the money
so you're like you know 100 bucks into
the trade close to 200 bucks at this
point because your entry is you know
77.60 you know we're trading 79
well it's called 79 here so it's about
you know 150 bucks but if this is the
problem is Traders tend to hold it too
long then this starts to happen
boom and it comes down to your stop out
so you're risking five ticks on the
trade
but your 15 ticks in the money for a
good portion of that trade
now you know people will make the
argument well you can try your stop up
okay but it's a slow moving Market
you're probably gonna get you probably
would have gotten stopped out at you
know maybe broke even as opposed to just
realizing hey you know what this trade
the move hasn't happened because if
you're getting long back here off this
big support of buying you want to see
the market build off that you want to
see the market you want to see more
buying coming in to move this higher and
if instead you don't see any of that
anymore chances are that move's not
going to happen
Okay so
you know on this video for there so if
you can understand right the things
you're looking at in the order flow
it's the same thing whether it's a
soybean meal whether it's five years
whether it's MES whether it's CL euro
currency
um you know but sometimes by going and
and watching
smaller markets I don't say slower
moving markets but smaller markets this
is a one minute chart
you can key in on certain aspects of the
order flow better than you know when
you're looking at something like
uh that was my e-mini footprint here
yeah that's not the mini Footprints I
got them all over the place here I got a
lot of charts I'm testing stuff on
um yeah where it's just you're just so
numb to the numbers where it's just you
know hundreds of contracts at each price
level you're just numb to it but if you
you go and you start watching it on a
slower moving Market you really start to
become sensitive on what to look for in
the market
okay so again thanks for the time
watching this video I hope you got
something useful out of it and have a
great rest of your weekend bye bye